male birth control no side effects it is
here a new procedure called reversible
inhibition of sperm under guidance is a
new effective a hundred percent
effective birth control for men what
they do it's an injection into the base
of the scrotum the vas deferens a lot of
terrible this pinhole into the scrotum
and then they pull out the vas deferens
and then they do it an injection of this
like Jo into that and then it's supposed
to like tear apart sperm as it passes
through that - thank you for even saying
that instead of having me read it this
sounds horrific to me but I have a
feeling you tube chicks are gonna be
okay with the 100% safe
doesn't sound as bad as supporting a kid
you didn't one for 18 years is true true
I I like that there's an alternative to
taking hormones because some women
myself included I can't handle it like
it makes me crazy right so it's good to
have an alternative but the question is
are guys gonna be willing to undergo
that type of procedure it is effective
for ten years but it's also reversible
reversible yeah it's reversible with an
injection of water and baking soda
apparently the water in baking soda will
get rid of that gel what happens if
someone makes you a cake before you
don't stick your dick in it I think I've
been so well-behaved here and out at the
end of the show you're telling me we can
spell by the way four-letter words oh
well you're not a dirty
oh my are you guys a little jealous that
when they finally come out with a male
thing like this except it's less so well
it's just easy it can be reversed
there's no problem there's no side
effects blah blah blah 100% infected
women you guys are going through
hormones all kinds of side effects stuff
than it's ever been 100% except do you
know yeah birth control meaning you're
not gonna get it right yeah okay yeah
birth control definitely has downside
it's like the mood swings
a lot of women lose their sex drive when
they're on the pill and hormones are
just terrible to be on for decades and
decades just plays havoc with your
health yeah and you know there's no
other thing that's 100% and you know if
this ectomy was actually snipping the
vas deferens so what's the difference
it's it's still that I'm sure it's under
anesthesia it's probably not as bad as a
colonoscopy and it's five minutes and
you're done and and you're good to go so
I think they should give you a sticker
and I voted and put it on your forehead
and which makes it look like I look
scripture for 18 years from half the
doctors out here well I had one of those
birth control things in the 90s I'm
still filling prescriptions in 2028
like this Pandora's box of crazy things
that could happen because a guy could
say to you oh well I had the procedure
because unless he gets a tattoo or ass
good say that with the vasectomy to true
I guess they could yeah yeah but do you
think maybe it would then open the door
for more STDs to be spread because
people go a woman may say well then he
doesn't have to wear a condom because
I'm pregnant different stories so even
now you know what the vasectomy I mean
it's still the same thing I just think
that you since there's no way to really
know you still have to get up close and
personal let's see if you see that
little mark that's what I'm saying they
needs to be some so nice now we'll walk
around lying about it and go I'm not
kidding look and you go you didn't he
goes yeah I didn't yeah that's fine can
you just hold a little longer
I'm sorry but you're holding it I just
don't see guys like lying about it yeah
no I don't think guys are like oh yeah
totally I got a I got those injections
and like purposely how is she isn't it
yeah you think they would lie wait till
you start dating oh it's such a big
world do you really think guys are gonna
lie guys do you lie about pretty much
everything I mean is that people lie
about intentions no of course I
understand that right but a guy doesn't
want to just get a girl pregnant right
like oh but a guy Seward you know a lot
of people have one-night stands and
there's nothing wrong with that and
there are guys who would just say pick
up at someone and say oh yeah I've had
that yeah it's way around the world you
know yeah
this almost strikes me as it's like a
little too evolved for Americans right
now this is only done in India right so
it seems like maybe that's okay there
for some reason but American guys I just
don't see American guys you're a guy in
your 20s you're single it doesn't strike
me as something that it could be great
for marriage because if you're married
and you're committed and then you've had
your kids and you really don't want to
use a condom or your wife is sick of
birth but it'd be a great thing to you
know when I met the first person I ever
met who had a vasectomy it was like such
freedom such freedom it was what it's
like I don't do put in contact lenses
anymore it's great I'm just I'm using in
men ah okay that was purely a metaphor I
didn't know what you were doing it was
great when I didn't have to put in
contact lenses for other things that it
wasn't God I know what I mean
Lenovo's is the official outfitter of
the Reuben report I want to put you in
this shirt go to bonobos calm enter code
TR are 2-0 for 20% off your first
purchase